A quick online search of Aspartame will provide
you with numerous opinions about this artificial
sweetener.
Some claim it causes things like cancer, seizures,
multiple sclerosis, lupus, memory problems
and brain tumors.
Just about every governmental organization
in the world, regulating food products, have
deemed it safe for human consumption.
(But, you know, just about every governing
body in the world still gets the “sodium
raises blood pressure” myth wrong, despite
overwhelming scientific evidence to the contrary,
so let’s not take their word on the whole
Aspartame thing!)
In an attempt to provide some sanity to the
controversy, let’s take an in-depth look
at this sweet, supposed compound-of-death
and see if we can’t make sense of the madness.
Aspartame was first developed by G.D. Searle
and Co in 1965.
In 1974, it gained approval from the FDA as
a food additive.
The benefit of using Aspartame over sugar
is the result of how sweet it is.
Sugar and Aspartame both produce about 4 calories
per gram.
Aspartame, however, is about 180 times sweeter
than sugar.
Thus, you need much less to get the same perception
of sweetness.
This is the reason it works so well as a low-calorie
sweetener.
Aspartame is made of the two amino acids,
phenylalanine and aspartic acid, and the alcohol,
methanol.
All of the health concerns regarding this
sweet supplement are a result of what those
three things can do to the body.
The question then becomes, do the three parts
of Aspartame cause health problems?
The quick answer is yes, at high enough levels
they do, but please don’t stop reading here-
the quick answer isn’t the whole answer.
So if high doses of Aspartame are harmful,
why are they allowed in our food?
It turns out, low doses aren’t harmful and
we even need those amino acids to perform
certain functions within the body.
In fact, phenylalanine and aspartic acid are
either produced by our bodies from many other
foods, or are already found naturally in our
diets.
Methanol, more commonly known as wood-alcohol,
is definitely not needed by our bodies.
If you’re wondering why it’s allowed in
Aspartame, it’s because it’s already found
in many drinks like wine, whiskey and beer.
As you might guess from the fact that humans
have been ingesting these for ages, at low
levels, it seems methanol has no long term
consequences.
That said, anything we take into our bodies
in high enough doses can be harmful.
Arguably, the most basic of human needs is
water.
Even water in high doses can kill you, in
what is being called water-intoxication.
An effect that leads to inadequate amounts
of salt in your blood, called hyponatremia.
While you may think this would never happen,
over the course of my career as a paramedic,
I’ve actually been on calls and seen people
die as a result of drinking too much water.
Exactly how this can take place and more specifically
what is going on in the body is a topic for
another article, though, as this one’s already
really long!
In the end, almost everything we take in needs
to fall within a certain range to be beneficial,
or at the least not overly harmful.
Some things even in miniscule doses can be
deadly.
For many others, it takes large doses to have
lasting negative effects.
The phrase, everything in moderation, comes
to mind here.
Since we already have Aspartame’s three
ingredients in many of the foods we eat, the
question of Aspartame’s safety is more appropriately:
are the levels found in Aspartame, and the
dose you may be ingesting, high enough to
cause unwanted health effects?
To answer that, I’ll need to go into a little
more depth on the aforementioned three things
that make up Aspartame.
Aspartic acid is one of the many amino acids
that help make the numerous proteins our bodies
use.
It helps the liver by aiding in the removal
of ammonia, and is involved in the production
of anti-bodies created by the immune system.
It can be found in many different types of
foods like asparagus, avocado’s, sugar beets,
sausages, and molasses.
Too much aspartic acid can be seen in several
different disease processes like: Lou Gehrig’s
disease, Epilepsy, and certain strokes.
Unfortunately for those fighting against Aspartame,
the levels seen in these conditions are several
fold higher than can be achieved by eating
Aspartame at recommended amounts.
There has also never been a direct cause and
effect shown between these diseases and increased
aspartic acid intake.
Methanol, in general, does result in some
unwanted reactions within the body.
Specifically, it’s taken up by the cells
of the body and the production of formaldehyde
and formic acid are the result.
Formaldehyde at high levels will cause proteins
to form abnormally.
The result is proteins that no longer function.
Formic acid, at high levels, will cause abnormal
metabolic processes within cells, causing
them to cease functioning.
The result is death to that cell due to a
lack of energy.
This is because it disrupts the organelle
responsible for a cells metabolism, known
as your mitochondria.
Some cells within the body are extremely sensitive
to formic acid, specifically the ones in the
optic nerve.
This is why blindness is associated with methanol
poisoning.
So does Aspartame produce enough methanol
to harm people?
Probably not.
There are numerous other foods we eat every
day that have the same, or higher, amounts
of methanol than Aspartame.
Beer and wine aside, foods like tomatoes (and
tomato juice), and citrus fruits and their
associated juices are good examples here.
This brings us to the last ingredient of Aspartame,
phenylalanine.
There is a rare disorder called Phenylketonuria
affecting about 1 in 10,000 people.
This ailment leaves your body an inability
to break down phenylalanine.
Left untreated, toxic levels of phenylalanine
build up.
The results can be things like developmental
disorders, cardiac rhythm problems, seizures
and severe learning disabilities.
Fortunately, most babies born in the developed
world are tested for this disorder and treatment
usually involves diet control.
Diet control because there are many foods
that contain higher levels of phenylalanine
than Aspartame.
Specifically, the many different types of
proteins we take in.
Knowing this disorder exists, the FDA requires
that Aspartame products be labeled specifically
for phenylketonuria patients.
Like any food additive evaluated by the FDA,
there is an extensive process that takes place
before manufacturers are allowed to put it
in our foods.
When the FDA first approved Aspartame as an
additive, there were numerous controversies
surrounding its approval.
Those controversies revolved around the studies
the FDA looked at, advocating Aspartame’s
safety.
That said, since its initial distribution
to the masses, there have been countless new
studies performed looking at Aspartame’s
safety.
Numerous other reviews of the research have
been conducted by several agencies, including
the FDA and the European Food Safety Authority
(EFSA).
The most recent was conducted by the EFSA
and issued on December 10, 2013.
That review looked at almost all studies performed
on Aspartame, in animal and human alike.
Knowing there is such a large controversy
surrounding the supplement, the EFSA’s independent
panel of experts issued an open public call
for any data, comments, or concerns on Aspartame.
According to Alicia Mortensen, chair of the
EFSA’s panel, “This opinion represents
one of the most comprehensive risk assessments
of Aspartame ever undertaken.”
The panel concluded that Aspartame does not
cause cancer at the levels consumed by humans,
and it doesn’t cause problems during pregnancy.
Overall, “There were no safety concerns
at the current ADI (acceptable daily intake)
of 40 milligrams per kilogram of body weight.”
For your reference, according to the American
Cancer Society (ACS), there are on average
about 180 mg of aspartame in a typical 12
ounce can of diet soda.
So an adult weighing 165 pounds would need
to drink about 16 cans of diet soda per day
to exceed the recommended limit, which itself
is set drastically below dangerous thresholds.
Specifically, according to the ACS, the acceptable
daily intake is set at “about 100 times
less than the smallest amount that might cause
health concerns, based on studies done in
lab animals.”
Not that you’d be able to in reality, but
if you actually managed to drink 1,600 cans
of diet soda in a day (one every 54 seconds),
you’ll have much bigger problems than aspartame
intake.
Even though the EFSA’s extremely comprehensive
review should have put this issue to rest,
there are researchers who still think they
didn’t go far enough.
Erik Millstone, a science and food policy
expert at the University of Sussex, UK, wrote
an open letter to colleagues in response to
the EFSA’s review.
In it, he states the panel knowingly ignored
studies showing negative effects of Aspartame
and deemed them unreliable.
All while the studies showing no ill effects
were deemed reliable.
The initial question then still remains.
Does Aspartame have negative health effects?
Some studies say it can and some say it can’t.
However, every study I could find showing
negative effects did so at levels not normally
consumed by any human.
(They were also all animal studies.)
Again, even water will kill you if you drink
too much of it.
In response to the numerous animal studies
that did show an increase in health problems
at high levels, Dr. David Hattan, acting director
of the Division of Health Effects Evaluation
in the FDA, states:
The legitimate attempts that have been made
to confirm and replicate allegations of adverse
reactions from Aspartame ingestion have not
been successful and the USFDA continues to
consider this to be among the most thoroughly
tested of food additives and this information
continues to confirm the safety of Aspartame.
In the end, at levels recommended by health
safety experts, Aspartame has never been shown
to result in negative health effects.
Should you want to get those unwanted health
problems, according to animal studies, just
consume an unrealistic amount of diet soft
drinks on a daily basis for several years.
Just remember, you would get the same problems
should you continually take in excessive amounts
of things like beer, wines, red meats, tomatoes,
and sugar beets over those same few years.
If you did, however, manage to drink this
much soda, whether you drank it with Aspartame
or sugar, you’re in for an awful lot of
other health problems which will most likely
kill you well before anything like cancer
from Aspartame.